that yeah but I'm saying like the girls
back then were skinnier
well skinnier they were smaller yeah
they were definitely smaller but you
know they couldn't be on the marketplace
putting themselves back out there to
find another man at 40. oh yeah yeah
so at that point it's going to be harder
for her to go find another man but it
was common to actually marry multiple
times
like that's why the divorce rate was
high back then because people would get
married three four five six times oh
interest I didn't know that but they had
to get married back then right right you
couldn't just be out here you could
womanize but it couldn't be public you
had to be married there was actually
Community kind of like you know you
don't have a wife
yeah but those those Roaring 20s didn't
like like our Roaring 20s 20 20.
back then they might hold to 26 and then
push the chips they said I looked up the
definition of a spinster spinster
how old 30. 26.
26. so you had Old Maid yeah spinster
yeah left over I mean these the things
that we're talking about now is what
people are they're like what but this
was common knowledge by a certain age is
over
yeah you're gonna be up forever you're
gonna be an auntie forever you know no
more kids for you but now we've trumped
it with science well you guys you guys
just well not even that I feel like you
guys just bail us out
yeah no I just mean like like men always
bail women out of their bad decisions
like you're forced to it's not even a
choice right but we're telling men don't
do that because it's a it's a lifelong
sentence that you're giving yourself
like you become a step daddy to bail out
a woman
even outside of that I'm talking about
like government benefits you guys pay
more into government benefits and we're
the we're the ones that are on them
yeah yeah I think it's worse now they
pay you to be a single mom at the UK you
get free housing you're a single mother
right but that was annoying so I was
like I didn't have any kids so can I get
rewarded there's no equity there's no
fairness in this thing here but you can
go out there and get knocked up if you
want I think I think the crazy thing is
the problem men have today is we've been
educated that men women are equal yeah
in a time where women were taken care of
them and bailed out there was a sense
that mineral providers this the role you
provide over here right and then if you
didn't provide that role you get kicked
the hell out and say all right you ain't
cooperating that's it or if he was an
alcoholic and abusive he loses that's
what divorce used to be but when no
fault divorce came in then it changed
the game and it swung the pendulum
swiftly to the point where now our
generation and younger we're dealing
with the realities of these women are
equal but I owe them child support I
gotta fight for my kids
they get alimony but we're equal in
society it doesn't make sense how did no
fault divorce swing the pendulum the
noble divorce allowed women to get
incentivized to bust up marriages with
no excuse
see before you needed a reason you
needed to hire a private investigator
and follow your husband to the hotel
with his secretary right or you need to
have been abused you needed you needed a
reason they would have to go to the
court and say well why are you divorcing
this man at that point women didn't file
80 percent divorces they probably filed
probably less than half
men probably filed the divorces but once
they said you don't need a reason
divorce rate skyrocketed and then women
can go in and say he's cheap um I'm he's
worth more
divorced than married
well and then you see a lot of the
government like programs come in too the
government programs like the the welfare
and that type of thing yeah and child
tax credits and all these things like
that yeah because I'm like why are we
paying people to be single mothers
that's what I don't understand
well you incentivize people to have be
single mothers and of course they're
paid to do it and I remember when I
lived in the midwest when I was younger
women would stay getting knocked up by
multiple Millions yeah they would be
like and there would be mothers telling
their daughters to get pregnant
and that's why teenage pregnancy was
super high because the mothers would if
they were if the women were shiftless
and lazy as mothers they would have
daughters and the daughters would be 15
and 16. they were like girl you can get
300 a kid a month
and so those girls would have three four
kids
and then it's a vicious cycle because
I I cringe to think that 300 a kid is
free money I couldn't do it but if you
think some people are like that's good
money yeah
I mean it's like to me I think it's
absolutely crazy but to uh but to a
person who's a loser they're like I
could get money by just having sex and
getting knocked up and had that three
four tie and had that for 25 years
essentially they have it for 20 25 years
yeah yeah three or four kids and even if
you have
um different fathers
you get more per father I don't know if
you know that no I didn't know that okay
so so let me get this straight they're
paying women not only to be single
mothers but they're paying them to get
pregnant by multiple people correct so
if I let's just say for instance I had
four kids by one person the state will
acknowledge that right
but if if if she has four different men
but they only have one kid right that
person can pay more in child support per
kid but I have I have three I have four
kids with her and I have another kid
over here
I'm gonna pay less per kid to her but if
it's four different men it's four
different
payments it's it's actually an incentive
for them to get Knocked Up by multiple
men
so it's a game it's a weird get but God
people have to understand people women
play that game they sit around
calculating this [ __ ] and they'd be like
all right come over here and they get
listen I don't know if your audience
knows getting pregnant is hard
well there's 40 that's fine when the
girls come on they say that it just
happened I don't know what do you mean
just have there's 41 forms of birth
control there's 41 400 birth control
ovulate like three days three days a
month
protect it and you got to have the egg
reach the sperm reach the egg which is
mathematically almost a miracle and then
you have to have the baby deliver which
is a miracle I don't know if you guys
your audience knows always tell my
people your Miracles right this act is
miraculous you're it's like the odds are
low
but these people do it three four five
times to me it's intentional it's really
intentional when you see what happens
out of here
um that these people keep getting
knocked up is completely intentional and
then what you got birth control so if I
wear a gun how did I get how do I get
you knocked up I mean the mathematics
and there's abortion too like I mean
yeah I mean like I'm personally pro-life
but like you you can you can get like
right it's if you if you said I can't
afford to have this kid I need child
support and you could have you could
have terminated you could have it's
ended up for adoption you could have not
got pregnant because you were unable to
uh afford the child but but you keep
getting pregnant that's it and I that's
the crazy thing every person I know
that's like had an like irresponsible
pregnancy right they're just Reckless
they're just it was I'm just like what
on Earth to your audience the worst
thing a woman can ever be in life is a
single mother you heard it here first
yeah I agree with you yeah
so I have no sympathy for single mothers
out here although I was raised by a
single mother but I always tell my
daughter never be that I mean you
basically just complicating life and
you're penalizing the child
um and you're gonna just basically ruin
the child that's what you're gonna do as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible